flying business class has long been
unaffordable for most people and
increasingly for companies as well a
round-trip business class flight from
New York to Sydney can cost more than
twenty thousand dollars roughly double
its pre-pandemic price Delta and British
Airways are charging more than 10 000 to
fly from London to New York next month
according to kayak.com while in New York
to Shanghai round trip can cost over 16
000.
flights have become pricey because
demand is outstripping Supply airlines
are struggling to reactivate their
fleets and bring back staff to meet the
increased appetite for travel right as
vacationers flush with cash book up
higher end seats on the corporate side
Zoom has proven it's become easier and
cheaper to get business done through
video conferencing leaving companies to
scrutinize travel budgets more than ever
it's all bad news for Airlines business
Travelers represent 75 percent of a
carrier's profit but only 12 percent of
passengers
the global business travel Association
says any rebound to pre-pandemic
corporate travel spending of 1.4
trillion dollars won't come until 2026.
[Music]